y comenzamos hablando de el tenis porque
de este lunes 29 de agosto los mejores
raquetas se darán cita en el complejo
pili jean king o el centro nacional de
tenis de eeuu para lo que será la
edición 142 del hueso pero abierto de
eeuu este año el evento que marca el
último gran slam de la temporada tiene
una atención especial pues será el
último que dispute en la tenista
estadounidense serena williams que
cuenta con seis títulos en esta
competición serena que cumplirá 41 años
el 26 de septiembre ha manifestado que
tras participar en este torneo comenzará
una etapa de transición hacia nuevas
cosas así que ya veremos
por supuesto que los amantes del tenis
estarán atentos a la segunda más
ganadora de torneos de gran slam con 23
su primer partido será frente a la
montenegrina tanca kovinic omar que
podemos esperar de serena williams para
este torneo donde ya anunció que va a
jugar el dobles junto a su hermana
recibiendo una invitación del comité
organizador y ya con 40 años a cuestas y
una temporada sobre todo en estos
últimos años que no las ha tenido todas
consigo sí totalmente inusual lo que
vamos a ver el día de mañana cuando se
enfrente a la atleta montenegrina danka
kovinic
porque no es habitual que una jugadora
que proviene de un well car y otras no
sembradas jueguen el partido estelar el
prime time en la cancha central y el
foco creo como tú lo mencionas estará
más que todo en los dobles recordemos
venus y serena williams
acumulan 14 títulos de grand slam entre
las dos y tres medallas de oro olímpicas
entran en circunstancias distintas no
vienen en su mejor momento las dos
ingresan al yo es open por la vía de los
wild cards invitaciones especiales creo
que va a ser una circunstancia más bien
emotiva más allá de los resultados que
históricamente ellas han conseguido como
pareja